YES, IT WILL.
THAT IS WHY -- WE'LL TALK SOME
MORE ABOUT THIS.
GENTLEMEN, THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
WE'VE GOT TO BE HERE.
THE BORDER WALL IS ONCE AGAIN
TAKING CENTER STAGE AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOT WAITING
ON CONGRESS TO KEEP MOVING
FORWARD ON BUILDING IT.
1 OF 4 COUNTRIES SELECTED TO
BUILD A CEMENT PRODUCT TYPE AND
THE CEO JOINS US NOW WITH MORE.
TOMMY, YOU HAVE DESIGNED A BIG,
BIG WALL.
I HAVE SEEN SOME PICTURES OF IT.
IT IS 1 OF 4 PROTOTYPES.
THE LACK OF FUNDING IS THERE
FROM CONGRESS.
GIVE US A SENSE, HOW BIG IS THAT
WHILE THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT A
PICTURE OF RIGHT NOW?
>> ARIS IS A WALL, NOT A
SEE-THROUGH FRIENDS, IT'S AN
ACTUAL WALL.
IT IS 30 FEET TALL, 30 INCHES
THICK OF CONCRETE, AND IT WILL
WORK.
ONE OF THE THINGS, WE PUT A
PROPOSAL ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY'S DESK TO
BUILD A 700 MILES IN ROUGHLY
FIVE YEARS THROUGH CALIFORNIA,
NEW MEXICO, AND ARIZONA,
COMPLETE WITH HIGH-SPEED ROADS
FOR THE AGENTS THAT WILL
ACTUALLY WORK.
FOR 10.77 BILLION, BACKED BY A
BOND.
THERE IS NO CAPITAL OVERRUNS.
WE ARE HERE TO DO EXACTLY WHAT
WE NEED TO DO.
BORDER SECURITY FOR EVERY SINGLE
AMERICAN.
WE CAN PROVE IT WORKS.
>> Jason: YOU'VE GOT PLACES
WITH RIVERBEDS, MOUNTAINOUS
AREAS, PARTICULARLY IN
NEW MEXICO.
WHAT DO YOU DO ON THOSE
PORTIONS?
IS THE WALL FOR THE ENTIRE SPAN?
>> ABSOLUTELY, NO EXCEPTIONS FOR
MOUNTAINS.
WITH OUR PRESIDENT SYSTEMS, WE
DO STEP FOOTINGS ON THE BOTTOM,
WE KEEP A CONSISTENT TOP.
WE CAN GO UP 17% GRADES AND
BUILD THE ROADS THAT THE AGENTS
CAN.
AND FURTHERMORE, I INCLUDED A
SMALLER PROPOSAL TO BUILD
15 MILES IN ONE YEAR.
SO THAT CURRENT FANS THEY ARE
BUILDING RIGHT NOW AND CALEXICO,
THE GOVERNMENT HAS GIVEN
BASICALLY 300 DAYS TO BUILD
2 MILES.
WITH ONE CREW, WE CAN BUILD
15 MILES.
SO THE DIFFERENCE IS, WE ARE
BUILDING A WALL, NOT A FENCE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD IT RIGHT.
CONGRESS DID NOT DO HIM JUSTICE
BY BASICALLY LIMITING THE ONLY
THING THEY COULD SPEND IS ON
OFFENSE, AN OUTER WALL.
IMAGINE IF GENERAL JIM MATTIS
GOT IN THE MILITARY BUDGET GOT A
700 MILLION BUT THERE WAS AN
CAVEAT THAT YOU COULD ONLY BUILD
OLD MILITARY OPTIONS THAT DON'T
WORK.
BASICALLY THE FENCE WEARS OUT IN
30 YEARS, BEST-CASE SCENARIO.
I'VE GOT PLACES WHERE IT RESTED
IN BASICALLY TEN YEARS.
OUR POINT IS --
>> Jason: WHAT ABOUT THE
POINT, PEOPLE HAVE SAID, IF YOU
BUILD A WALL, WE'LL JUST BUILD A
TUNNEL?
THERE REALLY ARE INTELLIGENCE OF
BEING ABLE TO DETECT A TUNNEL.
WHAT DO WE DO THEN?
HOW FAR DOWN INTO THE GROUND IS
THAT WHILE GOAL?
>> IT GOES 6 FEET.
WE HAVE WAYS, IF YOU COVER UP
WHERE OUR FOOTINGS WORK, YOU CAN
TRACK TUNNELS TO WITHIN TWO OR 3
TRACK TUNNELS TO WITHIN TWO OR F
TRACK TUNNELS TO WITHIN TWO OR E
TRACK TUNNELS TO WITHIN TWO OR T
TRACK TUNNELS TO WITHIN TWO OR O
TRACK TUNNELS TO WITHIN TWO OR F
TRACK TUNNELS TO WITHIN TWO OR V
TRACK TUNNELS TO WITHIN TWO OR S
TRACK TUNNELS TO WITHIN TWO OR B
TRACK TUNNELS TO WITHIN TWO OR L
TRACK TUNNELS TO WITHIN TWO OR T
TRACK TUNNELS TO WITHIN TWO OR .
WHEN I PUT TWO HIGH-SPEED ACCESS
ROADS ON BOTH SIDES OF THE WALL,
YOU HAVE VIEWS BOTH WAYS.
BASICALLY IF THEY DID BUILD A
TUNNEL, WE COULD PULL RIGHT UP
ON A ROAD, JUST LIKE USEFUL
IN -- YOU COULD FILL IT UP FULL
OF GRAVEL.
>> Jason: HAVE YOU HAD PEOPLE
TRYING TO GO OVER IT?
>> NO.
THINK ABOUT THIS, JASON, YOU'LL
HAVE AN ACCESS ROAD FOR THE PART
OF PATROL AGENTS THAT'S SITTING
40 FEET OFF THE BORDER RIGHT NOW
THAT THEY ARE ON THE PAVED ROAD
THAT THE AGES CAN'T BE
DETECTIVE.
YOU NEED TO PUT UP A LADDER OR
AN AGENT CAN DRIVE UP ON YOU?
THAT WOULD BE LIKE ASKING YOU TO
PUT UP A LADDER ON THE HIGHWAY
AND THE BORDER AGENTS ARE COMING
EVERY COUPLE MINUTES.
WHEN WE BUILD WHAT WE CAN BUILD,
LITERALLY, THOSE AGENTS CAN
TRAVEL 6-10 TIMES AS FAST AS
THEY DO BECAUSE THEY HAVE
ACCESS.
IN THE END, YOU HAVE TO BUILD A
BARRIER.
OUR BARRIER LASTS 150 YEARS.
THEN WE'VE GOT TO GIVE ACCESS TO
THE AGENTS SO THEY CAN PROTECT
EVERYONE OF OUR LIVES.
>> Jason: LISTEN, IT'S AN
INTERESTING PROTOTYPE.
I KNOW THERE ARE THREE OTHERS
THAT HAVE ALSO GOT AN    APPROVE
THAT HAVE ALSO GOT AN    APPROV.
THE WALL WORKS.
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO HELP THE